i bet he can't wait to talk to me after
all these years
i have very fond memories of you
um having quite a bit to drink before
you would come out
on the show to calm your nerves and then
you'd be
fent
[Laughter]
please tell me you're in london please
tell me you're someplace where
no i'm in new york city home of the
brave i am in new york
uh it's beautiful it's blustery it's
cold
it's um yeah but it's also let me see
here
okay it's a little after three o'clock
in the afternoon
sure you're fine yeah i thought you were
were you about to be judgmental yes very
true
it's fun i don't give a [ __ ] when we're
going to do the interview now and i'm
going to really sort of
take on kind of a nasty persona and go
after you
afterwards i just wanted to get on first
and have a nice chat with you and then
totally switch
paul bettany if that's your real name
all right
let's start there it says here
uh all right let's do it yeah let's do
it or should i say
hair better me nice
it says here you flat your family fled
to argentina
1946 is that right here bethany
yeah you're a little blunt
you were part of a um
all right here we go i guess no more
laughing and having fun let's do the
interview for television here we go
my guest tonight is an extremely
talented actor who's appeared in
numerous films including avengers
infinity war
captain america civil war and avengers
age of
ultron and addition to many many other
great films
now he stars in one division on disney
plus
it is the show of the hour everyone's
talking about it uh please welcome the
extraordinarily talented paul
bettany paul how are you i'm tickly boo
how are you i don't know what that means
that sounds like a character in winnie
the pooh
it is it is i like uh
you know i have to take a second here to
talk about your incredible
wife uh jennifer connolly i know that
um i'm gonna tell you uh something i've
not revealed
uh which is that your wife jennifer was
on my show way back in 1993
and um i my heart exploded
i was i just instantly so smitten with
her
um and she's a
massive i had a massive crush
on jennifer connolly uh which remains to
this day
uh and i've been told to keep my
distance uh we've worked it out with
your security people
um i think i've been appropriate uh but
um i know that you
also uh had a crush on on your wife
long before you met her is that right
yes i just want to say you're not alone
uh and you know there is a support group
i want to go to this support group
please and we can be in this
together yes it's true i did i did have
a
crush on her i don't think i'm alone in
having a crush on her
but i just want to clarify that because
i
you know i'm hurtling towards my dotage
i'm 49 years old
and uh when i had a crush on her which
we i
you know i was like 14. all right
because because she was
she was 14 15 in when she was in
labyrinth so it always sounds a bit
weird saying
i fell in love with her the first time i
saw her in lebanon
yes you sound like a you can sound like
a creep unless you specify
that you were 14 uh
and uh it was a crush from afar which is
always appropriate
yeah totally i sat outside our house i
saw her comings and goings
you know i that's where i met you
i i met you because i was in some bushes
trying to get just a glimpse of this
beautiful and talented jennifer connolly
and suddenly someone was taking my usual
spot in the bushes and i'm like we had a
wonderful chat that day
[Laughter]
yes it's true i i did have a crush on
jennifer
which um is a little bit pathetic but
you know
no guess what it worked out i mean i
i tip my imaginary cap to you